MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ARCHULETA ATKINS EIGHTY BACKER
FORAGES BRADFORD BY ADAM CORTEZ
C. DALLEY DIED IN ALSO EXAMINE
LASER GUNS OLIVE GROVE HURTS FOR
WEST SO HER TADO JONES CAN
LONGER LAYERED LABOR. THE MON
MCGUIRE. MELINDA'S MAN NEWMAN
NIELSEN A TELEPHONE HANDS
FOURTEEN TINO ROSSI RUBIO
SKINNER TURN ON BERG CASKEY
WEINER WELL. MEMBERS IF YOU
COULD TAKE YOUR SEATS PLEASE. A
CORONER IS PRESENT. WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY SENATOR
EDMUND AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
BY SENATOR ROB. SHE'S. AS WE
BEGIN THIS NEW YEAR OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WE PONDER THE WORDS
OF HOWARD THURMAN. WHEN THE SONG
OF THE ANGELS ARE STILL WHEN THE
STAR IN THE SKY IS GONE WHEN THE
KINGS AND PRINCES ARE HOME WHEN
THE SHEPHERDS ARE BACK WITH
THEIR FLOCKS THEN THE WORK OF
THE NEW YEAR BEGINS. TO FIND THE
LOST TO HEAL THE BROKEN TO FEED
THE HUNGRY. TO RELEASE THE
PRISONER TO REBUILD THE NATION
AND THE STATE TO BRING PEACE
AMONG PEOPLE TO MAKE MUSIC. IN
THE HEART THIS IS THE WORK THAT
WE'RE ABOUT TO DO IN THE SENATE
AND WE PRAY. MAY THE LORD BLESS
US AND KEEP US MAY GOD'S FACE
SHINE UPON US AND BE AS GRACIOUS
TO US MAY GOD LOOK UPON US
KINDLY AND GIVE US PEACE. A MAN
. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. MEMBERS WELCOME BACK HAPPY
NEW YEAR TO IT TO YOU ALL
MEMBERS THE NEXT ORDER OF
BUSINESS IS REMARKS BY THE
PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE EIGHT
SENATOR ATKINS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- IT IS A LITTLE HARD
TO HEAR IN THE CHAMBER I'M NOT
SURE IF THE SOUND SYSTEM IS.
DIFFERENT BUT- TO MY COLLEAGUES
. IF WE COULD. THANK YOU I DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S ONLY ME I'VE GOTTEN
A LITTLE BIT OLDER MAYBE I CAN'T
HEAR AS WELL BUT- I THINK I'M
BLAMING IT ON THE SOUND SYSTEM-
WILL GOOD AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES
AND HAPPY NEW YEAR. IT IS A NEW
YEAR. AND THERE'S A LOT OF NEW
THINGS GOING ON AROUND US
OBVIOUSLY. WE'VE SEEN THE
OUTCOME OF REDISTRICTING MANY OF
US ARE REPRESENTING THE
COMMUNITIES WE WERE ELECTED TO
REPRESENT AND- BUT WE'RE GOING
TO BE AWARE OF NEW COMMUNITIES
THAT EVENTUALLY WILL BE PART OF
THOSE DISTRICTS SO. WE'RE GOING
TO BE WORKING FROM OUR NEW
TEMPORARY SPACE. AND THAT'S A
LOT OF NEW TO WRAP OUR HEADS
AROUND. BUT IT'S ALSO EXCITING
AND IT'S ENERGIZING WITH MANY
OPPORTUNITIES TO BUILD ON THE
HISTORICMOMENTUM OF THE LAST
YEAR. NO ONE CAN SEE ALL THAT
THE YEAR AHEAD WILL BRING US.
THOUGH SOMETIMES I REALLY
SUSPECT THAT JERRY BROWN CANNON
HE JUST DOESN'T ALWAYS SHARE IT
WITH THE REST OF US. THERE WILL
BE SOME ROUGH PATCHES OF COURSE.
THE HOPEFULLY NOT AS ROUGH AS
SOME OF WHAT WE HAVE FACED THESE
PAST COUPLE YEARS. AND I WANT TO
START THIS YEAR BY THANKING MY
COLLEAGUES THANKING THE MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE. FOR HANDLING
THOSE ROUGH SPOTS WITH THE
CIVILITY AND RESPECT THAT SEEMS
TO BE MISSING. AND A LOT OF
PLACES THESE DAYS. I ALSO WANT
TO THANK SECRETARY CONTRAIRE US
IN THE RULES COMMITTEE STAFF.
ESPECIALLY OUR FACILITY STAFF
LED BAR DEPUTY SECRETARY TONY
BRENNER. FOR THEIR AMAZING ABOVE
AND BEYOND EFFORTS TO GET US ALL
INTO THAT NEW SPACE. AS WE START
THIS NEW YEAR THANK YOU. I'M
SURE TONY'S NOT LISTENING
BECAUSE SHE'S BUSY WORKING BUT I
HOPE YOU WILL SHARE WITH HER OUR
APPRECIATION. I HAVE TO TELL YOU
THAT I AM REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE HAVE
THIS YEAR TO MAKE THINGS BETTER
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS WORKING
TOGETHER. AND I COULDN'T HAVE
ASKED FOR A BETTER GROUP OF
CALLINGS TO HELP MAKE THE MOST
OF THOSE OPPORTUNITIES SO I WANT
TO THANK YOU. AND HERE'S TO A
GREAT TWENTY TWENTY TWO DESPITE
ALL OF THE- OBSTACLES THAT MAY
BE PLACED IN OUR WAY AND MAN
AND- PRESIDENT I DON'T KNOW IF.
MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUE WANTS TO
MAKE A COMMENT I KNOW THAT- THE
REPUBLICAN REPUBLICAN LEADER IS
NOT HERE BUT I KNOW THAT. IT
WOULD BE NICE IF OFF. THE
SENATOR. WONDERFUL SENATOR JOHNS
THANK YOU SENATOR JONES THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND MADAM OF
PROTEIN PRESIDENT THE- WELCOME
HAPPY NEW YEAR ON BEHALF OF- THE
REPUBLICAN LEADER SCOTT WILK I
GET THE HONOR AND PLEASURE OF
WELCOMING US ALL BACK I HEARD A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS ON THE WAY
INTO THE CAPITOL TODAY ONE WAS
IT'S LIKE THE FIRST DAY OF
SCHOOL- WHICH IT CERTAINLY IS
OFTEN HAS THAT FEELING AND WHEN
WE COME BACK IN JANUARY. AND THE
SECOND ONE THAT I HEARD TODAY
WAS WE'RE GONNA HAVE SOME
GROWING PAINS AND I THOUGHT THAT
WAS VERY POIGNANT AS WE'RE
MOVING INTO A NEW OFFICE
BUILDING AND FINDING OUR WAY
AROUND- YOU KNOW THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS ALL OVER AGAIN FOR THOSE
OF US THAT HAVE BEEN HERE FOR A
WHILE IT IS EXCITING. TO HAVE A
NEW OFFICE BUILDING AND NEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR. MAKING
FRIENDS ON THE FLOORS ARE NEW
FLOORS. ON SPEAKING ABOUT MAKING
NEW FRIENDS MANY OF US WILL BE
IN A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
DISTRICTS NEXT YEAR. IF WE ARE.
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY COME BACK.
BY OUR CONSTITUENTS SO IT'S
GOING TO BE AN EXCITING
INTERESTING. HOPEFULLY FIND
HERE. I DO WANT TO UNDERSCORE
AND AGREE AND AGREE WITH THE PRO
TEM. ON THE CIVILITY OF THIS
HOUSE VERSES WHAT WE ARE SEEING
AROUND THE COUNTRY. AND
HOPEFULLY AS WE FINISH OUT THE
THIS LEGISLATIVE SESSION WILL BE
ABLE TO MAINTAIN THAT DECORUM
WHILE ALSO HAVING VIGOROUS
DEBATE. ON THE ISSUES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO ALL OF US AND OUR
CONSTITUENTS. AND FOR THOSE AND
I HAVEN'T LOOKED TO SEE WHO THAT
IS BUT I KNOW SOME OF THIS MAY
BE YOUR LAST YEAR. AND EIGHT
MONTHS GOES BY REALLY FAST HERE.
SO MY ENCOURAGEMENT. FOR THOSE
IT THIS IS YOUR LAST YEARS TO
MAKE THE MOST OF IT. WORK QUICK
WORK- HAPPILY. AND LET'S MAKE A
DIFFERENCE FOR THE- CALIFORNIANS
THAT WILL BE THAT WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS YEAR
AND THOSE OF US COMING BACK NEXT
YEAR- REPRESENTING NEXT YEAR SO
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPTION SHOWED. THIS
AFTERNOON WELCOME EVERYBODY
HAPPY NEW YEAR LET'S GET TO WORK. THANK YOU SENATOR JONES AND
HAPPY NEW YEAR TO EVERYONE OUT
WELCOME BACK TO THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS WE WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
SHORT MEETING TODAY BUT THERE IS
SOME IMPORTANT WORK THAT WE NEED
TO GET DONE SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE- YOUR ATTENTION TO IT
WE'RE MOVING ONTO PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR. CENTER GROVE. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I'M HONORED
IN SOMEWHAT SADDENED TODAY TO
ANNOUNCE THE RETIREMENT OF
RICHARD PAUL. WHO HAS SERVED AS
A VALUED PROFESSIONAL STAFF
MEMBER IN THE SENATE SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY TWO AND HAS
WORKED IN THE REPUBLICAN POLICY
OFFICE SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
NINE. PRIMARILY AS OUR CAUCUS
CONSULTANT FOR THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE. SENATE
REPUBLICAN LEADER WILKE WAS
SCHEDULED TO SPEAK FIRST ABOUT
RICHARD BUT SINCE HE WAS UNABLE
TO BE IN SACRAMENTO TODAY HE
ASKED ME TO LEAD OFF. IT HELPED
HIM PLAN TO HONOR RICHARD IN
PERSON TODAY ON THE FLOOR BUT
HIS BATTLE WITH CANCER IS
KEEPING HIM FROM BEING HERE. WE
WERE DEVASTATED THAT RICHARD
CAN'T BE WITH US ON THE FLOOR
TODAY BUT WE KNOW THAT HE'S
WATCHING THE SENATE FLOOR
SESSION. FROM HIS LAPTOP WHERE
HE'S CURRENTLY AT. I WANTED TO
PERSONALLY WELCOME HIM ALBEIT
VIRTUALLY- AND TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. I AM HONORED TO RISE
TODAY TO RECOGNIZE THE SERVICE
STRENGTH COURAGE. AND JUST
COMPLETE DEDICATION AND HARD
WORK OF OUR DEAR FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE RICHARD PAUL. I COULD
PROBABLY STAND HERE AND SPEAK
FOR AN ETERNITY ON THE MERITS OF
RICHARD'S WORK ON AS A COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT. IN ON HIS DEDICATION
TO THE FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM OR AS
A VOLUNTEER AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE RAILROAD MUSEUM. HOWEVER
TODAY I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT A
LITTLE ABOUT RICHARD'S HEALTH
JOURNEY AND HIS DEDICATION TO
BOTH PUBLIC SERVICE ABOVE ALL
ELSE. AS MANY OF YOU KNOW DURING
THE SUMMER OF TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN RICHARD WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH METASTATIC SARCOMA. IT'S A
VERY RARE FORM OF CANCER. THE
DISEASE SPREAD TO HIS SPINE
DAMAGED HIS SPINAL CORD AND IT
RESULTED IN A PARTIAL PARALYSIS
. RICHARD HAS BRAVED SEVERAL
SURGERIES IN TOWARD MULTIPLE
ROUNDS OF CHEMOTHERAPY AND SPENT
MONTH AFTER MONTH AND HOSPITALS
AND REHABILITATION FACILITIES
DURING HIS EXTENSIVE TREATMENT.
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF STANFORD
SARCOMA SPECIALIST DOCTOR
CHRISTINE HAND YOU A REMARKABLE
DEDICATED TEAM OF PHYSICIANS
NURSES. AND OTHER PROVIDERS HAVE
DELIVERED RICH RICHARDS
EXCEPTIONAL CARE. HOWEVER IT'S
RICHARD'S BROTHER BRAD. THAT HAS
STOOD BY HIS SIDE AS A PRIMARY
CARE GIVER IN SUPPORT SYSTEM. HE
IS THE EPITOME OF ABSOLUTE
SELFLESS LOVE. THE RESPECT AND
ADORATION ADORATION THAT I HAVE
FOR THESE CARETAKERS IS EXCEEDED
ONLY BY GRATITUDE THAT I
EXPRESSED TO THEM TODAY FOR ALL
THAT THEY HAVE GIVEN. MY
GRATITUDE ALSO EXTENDS TO ROGER
MADISON. AVENUE GALLERY.
RICHARDS CO WORKER AND LONGTIME
STEADFAST FRIEND ROGER HAS
SUPPORTED RICHARD IN EVERY
CAPACITY AND HAS ACTED AS OUR
PRINCIPAL LIAISON AS A SOURCE OF
UPDATES. I CAN'T THANK YOU
ENOUGH ROGER AT ALL FOR EVERY
TEXT MESSAGE EVERY EMAIL AND
EVERY PHONE CALL WHEN YOU WERE
ABLE TO SPEAK TO RICHARD SPEAK
TO RICHARD AND REPLAY HIS
CONDITION- I AM TO EACH ONE OF
US. I WANT YOU TO NOW THAT YOU
PROVIDED AND WAVERING SUPPORT TO
WHAT I THINK IS ARE PART OF A
POLICY M. FAMILY THE FAMILY THAT
WE LOVE AND TREASURE IN THIS
BUILDING. YOU WERE THE ONE THAT
GAVE US THE INFORMATION ON HOW
TO PRAY. JOIN TOGETHER AND ASK
GOD FOR FAVOR OVER THIS ILLNESS.
AND I JUST THANK YOU FOR BEING
THERE EVERY SINGLE DAY FOR ROGER
. I'M SORRY FOR RICHARD I
APOLOGIZE. AND DESPITE ALL THE
OBSTACLES AND CHALLENGES THAT
RICHARD HAD FACED HE IS NOT LET
THIS DISEASE DEFINE HIM OR HIS
SPIRIT. RICHARD B. M. BORN
RICHARD HAS BORNE ALL THE
SUFFERING AND YES THIS TRAGEDY
WITH EXTRAORDINARY COURAGE. AND
UNPARALLELED SPRING STREAM AND
REMARKABLE RESILIENCY. AND AN
ABSOLUTE GRACE. RICHARDS HEART
OF FAITH HAS NURTURED THE SOUL
FULL OF HOPE CARRYING THROUGH
THE MOST DIFFICULT YEARS. IN
SECURING IN HIS HEART AND MIND
THE KNOWLEDGE THAT HE IS THE SON
OF AN ALMIGHTY GOD. IT IS BEEN
AN ABSOLUTE HONOR BEING ABLE TO
WORK WITH RICHARD IN A
PROFESSIONAL CAPACITY THAT IS
DEVELOPED INTO A WONDERFUL
FRIENDSHIP OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS. HE IS FOR PROFESSIONAL
WORTHY OF RECOGNITION AND PRAISE
HIS DISTINGUISHED HIMSELF WITH
HIS UNWAVERING COMMITMENT TO
CIVIL SERVICE AND HIS DEDICATION
IN WORKING FOR THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. UNDER THE
MOST DIFFICULT PERSONAL
CIRCUMSTANCES. PRESIDENT WOODROW-WILSON ONCE SAID THE EAR OF THE
LEADER MUST RING WITH THE VOICES
WORK THROUGHOUT THE YEARS
REFLECTS HIS CALL TO INSURE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE RESPONDS TO THE
NEEDS OF THE CITIZENS AND HOW WE
CAN SERVE THE PEOPLE OF THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AS
THEY SAY LEADERSHIP IS SERVICE
NOT POSITION AND WE'RE FORTUNATE
TO WORK ALONGSIDE RICHARD AS A
LEADER AND A FRIEND SOME IN THIS
BUILDING FOR OVER THIRTY ONE
YEARS. ON A PERSONAL LEVEL
RICHARD AND I BECAME CLOSE
DURING THIS TIME. THAT I SPENT
AS THE MINORITY LEADER. I'M
BLESSED TO HAVE SAT WITH HIM AND
PRAYED WITH HIM TALK TO HIM
ENJOYED HIS WISDOM AND DIRECTION
. HAVE A SHARE THOSE MOMENTS
WITH HIM AND HAVE EXPERIENCED
THE PRESENCE OF HIS SOUL.
RICHARD HAS BEEN NOTHING LESS
THAN A BLESSING IN AN ABSOLUTE
PLEASURE TO WORK WITH AND I WILL
ALWAYS TREASURE TREASURE AT THE
TIME THAT WE SPENT. WINSTON
CHURCHILL EXPLAINED IT THIS WAY
WE MAKE A LIVING BY WHAT WE GET
WE MAKE A LIFE BY WHAT WE GIVE.
RICHARD GAVE. THIRTY ONE YEARS
TO THIS BUILDING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN DEDICATED SERVICE
IN HIS LIFE. RICHARD PAUL WE ARE
AMAZED AT YOUR STRENGTH DURING
THIS DIFFICULT BATTLE AND I WANT
TO RECOGNIZE YOUR DEDICATION TO
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
OVER THREE DECADES. WE STAND
WITH YOU AND WE WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT OUR PRAYER WARRIORS IN THIS
BUILDING ARE SPEAKING WITH A
PEACE AND STRENGTH AND HEALTH
AND HEALING OVER YOU. EVERY
SINGLE DAY. AS RICHARD IS THE
LONGEST SERVING MEMBER IN A
REPUBLICAN CAUCUSHE'S OFTEN
REFERRED TO AS THE DEAN OF THE
CAUCUS CONSULTANTS. SO IT'S NO
BETTER- FOLLOW THAT I INTRODUCE
THE DEAN OF THE SENATE- THAT HAS
WORKED WITH RICHARD FOR A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF YEARS TO
SPEAK ON RICHARD'S BEHALF AS
WELL. NIELSEN THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR. AND RICHARD. AS I HAVE
LOOKED AT THE CAMERA. I FEEL
THAT I'M LOOKING RIGHT AT YOU. I
FEEL YOUR PRESENCE HERE. IN THIS
INSTITUTION WITH US. YOU'RE NOT
PIPED IN BY VIDEO YOU'RE HERE
BECAUSE YOUR HEART TO SEE. I
LAUGHED AND TOLD COLLEAGUES
SIMPLY AS SENATE CONGRESS. YOU
KNOW THE ONES WHO REALLY COUNT.
ARE NOT THE ELECTED MEMBERS. BUT
THE PEOPLE WHO WORK HERE. THE
YOUNG SON. WHO WORK COUNTLESS
PREPARING MEMBERS TO DO THEIR
JOB ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE. HE
HAD TENDERED UC BERKELEY.
GETTING A DEGREE IN HISTORY.
WHICH RELATES TO SOMEONE ELSE
SPEAK OF LATER ALEX BASS. WHO IS
OUR RESIDENT THE STORY. AND GIVE
ME SOME INFORMATION. ABOUT RICH. HE WAS A SENATE FELLOW. A VERY
INTERESTING POSITION MOST OF US
HAVE ENJOYED FELLOWS IN OUR
OFFICE IS WORKING. WE KNOW WHAT
THAT MEANS. HE THEN HAS BECOME A
STEWARD OF THE MENTOR IN THE
SENATE FELLOWSHIP. AND WE MOST
OF US HAVE ENJOYED HAVING
FELLOWS. IN OFFICE. HE CAME HERE. FIRST WORKING. WITH SENATOR
BILL AND. THEN BILL BAKER. AND
ASSEMBLYMAN THE BAY AREA. BILL
WYMAN FROM TO HATCH. AND THEN HE
- HE BECAME. THE OTHER PART OF
THE SENATE FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM.
AND SERVED AS A GEO CONSULTANT
BROUGHT TO THAT POSITION. BUT
SENATOR KEN MADDY. A DEAR FRIEND
AND NOW DECEASED. BUT VERY MUCH
A PART. THIS INSTITUTION. CENTER
BOARD JUST NOW REPRESENTS FRESNO
I DO NOT REPRESENT IT. BUT I WAS
BORN THERE. WITH THE SCHOOL
THERE. IN MY HEART. IS THERE.
AND I KNOW HOW. IN NEW VERY WELL
. SENATOR MATT. HE SUCCEEDED ME
AS REPUBLICAN LEADER. KEN WAS A
VERY DISCERNING A MAN PERSON OF
THE SENATE. RICHARD COULD NOT
HAVE HAD. BETTER MENTAL. BUT THE
VALUE LADIES AND GENTLEMAN THE
SCENT OF AMENITY. IS WHAT DO
THEY GIVE BACK. AND THIS MAN HAS
GIVEN BACK SO MUCH. TO THE
CENTER. TO THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE. THE CALIFORNIA. THE GAO
COMMITTEE IS CALLED THE JEWISH
COMEDIANS. ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
TO SPEAK NEXT SERVICES SHARE.
THE ISSUES BEFORE THAT COMMITTEE
. A VERY AGONIZED. DIFFICULT
COMPLEX. DO IT. WHEN INDIAN
GAMING BECAME A PART OF
CALIFORNIA. HE PARTICIPATED IN
NEGOTIATIONS A MALL WAS PACKS.
COMMUNICATING THEIR VALUE. WHAT
WAS IN THEM UP WAS NOT. THEY
BECAME AN EXPERT. IN THAT VERY
UNIQUE NICHE. IT IS IN GAMING
CAN CALIFORNIA. A VERY IMPORTANT
PART THAT'S NOT JUST OUR ECONOMY
. BUT OF OUR CULTURE. AND HE
BECAME ONE OF THE ARCHITECTS. OF
WHAT WE NOW ENJOY. WITH THE
INDIAN GAME. HE LATER WORKED FOR
ROSS JOHNSON. FOR A TIME THEN HE
BECAME A PART OF THE REPUBLICAN
POLICY CONSULTANTS OFF. ESTEEMED
IN THOSE COUNCILS OF HIS PEERS.
WHEN THEY HEARD THAT I WAS GOING
TO MAKE SOME REMARKS. BUT THAT
MANY CALLS. FROM HIS PEERS WHO
HAD WORKED WITH HIM. BEHIND THE
SCENES SCENES THAT WE DID NOT
SEE. WE'RE NOT A PART OF. BUT
FROM WHICH WE GAIN THE VALUE. OF
THE WISDOM THAT HE IMPARTED. IN
THE RESIDENT HISTORY SO WHEN
VIEWED IN THE SPARE. AND SO.
ALEX VASSAR HAS TOLD ME THAT. HE
HAD BEEN. THE THIRTY ONE YEAR
CAREER. SERVING WITH FIVE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE.
LEGISLATORS OVER THOSE YEARS.
INCLUDING TWO HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN. STATE SENATOR. DURING
HIS TENURE. ALMOST THIRTY
THOUSAND BUILT THE BEEN SIGNED
INTO LAW. THAT'S NO MEAN FEAT TO
BE ABLE TO STORE THOSE BILLS
THROUGH AND COMMUNICATE TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE VARIOUS
COMMITTEES AND TO THE FLOOR. ON
THE MERITS AND THE DEMERITS. OF
THOSE MANY DEALS. HE WAS AN
AFICIONADO. OF TRAINS. HE LOVED
TRAINS. DO YOU KNOW HOW MUCH A
PART OF THE HISTORY OF THIS
STATE. THINGS ARE. I THINK OF
THE PROMONTORY POINT IN THE
DRIVING OF THAT. LAST SPIKE.
CONNECTED EAST AND WEST AND MID
WEST AMERICA. HE KNEW ABOUT THAT
. EVEN WAS TRAINED IF YOU WILL.
HE THEY HAD A HAD A ROLE WORKING
THROUGH THE- HISTORIC TRAIN
MUSEUM IN OLD SACRAMENTO JUST A
FEW BLOCKS AWAY FROM HERE. HE
LEARNED THE RULES OF BEING A
BRAKEMAN. A LOT OF COUNTRY SONGS
ABOUT THE BREAK. THEIR BRAVERY.
IT IS A CONDUCTOR. HE WAS A
MAINTENANCE OF WAY TECHNICIAN.
AND HE BURNED A FEDERAL
CERTIFICATE. AS A SHIP TO
CERTIFY. THE SAFETY OF OUR
RAILROADS. AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BAKERSFIELD IS MENTIONED HE'S
COME UP ON A STUMBLE ALONG THE
WAY. WE NEVER KNOW WHEN THOSE
MOMENTS THEY OCCUR. IN OUR LIVES. THAT IS NOT THE QUESTION. THE
QUESTION IS HOW DO WE- HOW DOES
RICHARD DEAL. WITH THAT
SITUATION. AS HE IS NOW AND WHAT
CAN WE DO ABOUT. I ALWAYS FIND
REFUGE IN PEACE IN MY HEART AND
SOUL IN PRAYER- CERTAINLY THAT'D
RICHARD TO MY PRAYERS. AND I
KNOW THAT THOSE WILL TOUCH IT.
AND HAVE THEIR VALUE. TO HIM.
AND I KNOW THE LORD DOES LISTEN
. TO ALL OF US. I WAS TOLD ONE
TIMER ASKED BY SOMEONE TO PRAY
FOR THEM. BECAUSE JIM GARD
LISTENS TO YOU. NO I LAUGHED AND
I SAID NO. GOD LISTENS TO
EVERYBODY. IF I HAVE ANY
PURCHASE WITH THE LORD JUST I
HAVE A LOT MORE TO PRAY ABOUT
THE MANY. WELL RICHARD IS ONE
THAT WE SHOULD DO TO ADD TO OUR
PRAYERS NOW. THIS IS A
CHALLENGING TIME. AND ALL MY
PRAYERS. FOR RICHARD. THERE'S A
VERSE IN THE BIBLE. MAY THE
PEACE OF GOD WHICH SURPASSES ALL
UNDERSTANDING. GUARD YOUR
HEARTS. AND MINDS THROUGH CHRIST
JESUS. I BELIEVE THAT RICHARD
FEELS THAT PRESENCE IN HIS LIFE
. IN AN HOUR SOLILOQUIES HEREIN
ARE TESTIMONIES TO HIM. BECAUSE
TO BE REMINDED OF THAT AGAIN. TO
RELIVE THE WONDERFUL MOMENTS OF
HIS LIFE AND WONDERFUL
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT HE WROTE
HERE. AND HE- LIKE HIS MENTORS
INCLUDING CENTER MAY. WILL LIVE
ON IN THIS INSTITUTION. MANY
MEMBERS ARE. ULTIMATELY NOT TOO
MEMORABLE. BUT SOME DO LIVE ON
WITHIN CTM INTO INSTITUTION. AND
EVEN FEWER STAFF. OREGON
RECOGNIZED OR REMEMBERED. WHEN
I'M CRUISING AROUND THE CAPITAL
. EVERY DAY. I MENTIONED TO THE
FOLKS. THOSE UNKNOWN VOICES. THE
GIVE US GOOD COUNSEL. PLATING.
DOES IT- JANET. PARKER CARS. THE
SPECIAL SERVICES. THEY'RE THE
ONES. THERE ARE THE ARCHITECTS
OF OUR SUCCESS. IT IS NOT ABOUT
US IT'S ABOT WHAT THEY GIVE US.
AND WHAT THEY THREW US. GET TO
THIS INSTITUTION. THE GOVERNOR
OF THE STATE. RICHARD HAS BEEN A
PART. OF ALL OF THAT. FOR OVER
THREE DECADES. WE WISH YOU PEACE
OF HEART. I UNDERSTAND. OF
STRENGTH. THESE CHALLENGING
TIMES. AND WHEN- NOTWITHSTANDING
ANY CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE. WE
LOOK TO THE LORD. HE WILL BRING
US THAT PEACE. WHICH SURPASSES
ALL UNDERSTANDING. FATHER IN
HEAVEN MAY THAT BE. RICHARDS
REWARD. YOUR GRACE BE UPON HIM
YOUR BLESSINGS BE UPON HIM. AND
LET HIM LIVE FULLY EVERY SINGLE
DAY AND MOMENT. BEFORE YOU TAKE
IT HOME. SENATOR DODD. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS AS
CHAIR OF THE SENATE GEO I'M
HONORED TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SAY A FEW WORDS ABOUT THE
DISTINGUISHED CAREER OF RICHARD
PAUL. WHEN I FIRST BECAME CHAIR
OF GEO MY COMMITTEE STAFF WAS
ADAMANT THAT THE THAT RICHARD
COULD BE ONE OF THE FIRST PEOPLE
THAT I MEET. HIM WHEN I MET HIM.
I UNDERSTOOD EXACTLY WHY THEY
HAD THAT IT MIGHT. NOT ONLY WAS
INCREDIBLY KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT
THE ISSUES. BUT HE WAS
ABSOLUTELY HONEST AND COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH ME AND MY STAFF
AND OPEN AND BIPARTISAN MANNER.
A COMMITMENT. THAT HAS NEVER
FALTERED. THROUGHOUT MY
CHAIRMANSHIP HE'S BEEN A
SOUNDING BOARD FOR MY STAFF
TOGETHER THEY'VE HELPED ME IN
SHARING WHAT I HOPE IS A WELL
RUN COMMITTEE THAT WORKS ACROSS
THE AISLE TO IMPROVE THE LIVES.
OF EVERYBODY IN THE STATE. AT A
TIME WHEN BIPARTISANSHIP IS
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO ACHIEVE. I
HOPE WE CAN TAKE RICHARD'S
COMMITMENT AS AN EXAMPLE OF HOW
POLICY CAN BE IMPROVED. BY
WORKING TOGETHER. FOR EVERYONE
HERE SAID BILLS REFERRED TO GEO
I CAN TELL YOU THAT MANY TIMES
THE REASON WHY YOUR BILLS
RECEIVE THAT NUMBER OF VOTES
THAT THEY DID. WAS BECAUSE OF
THE WORK THAT RICHARD DID BEHIND
THE SCENES TO ENSURE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. I CAN I HOPE WE CAN
TAKE THAT ALL. TAKE A MOMENT
TODAY TO APPRECIATE THAT WORK.
MY COMMITTEE STAFF OTH PAST AND
PRESENT ALSO WANTED ME TO
PUBLICLY SHARE THEIR GRATITUDE
NOT ONLY FOR ALL YOUR HELP. BUT
FOR YOUR FRIENDSHIP AS WELL
RICHARD. THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
EVERY MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE
IN ALL THE STAFF HERE OWES YOU A
GREAT AMOUNT OF GRATITUDE I HOPE
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT YOUR WORK
HAS AND WILL ALWAYS BE
APPRECIATED. RICHARD THERE ARE
SO MANY MORE WORDS I COULD SAY.
ULTIMATELY THOUGH SOMETIMES THE
SIMPLEST WORDS SAY IT BEST.
THANK YOU. SENATOR JONES. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
RICHARD GOD BLESS YOU. AND WE
ARE GIVING YOU OUR GREATEST
GREETINGS FOR YOUR RETIREMENT.
AND I JUST WANT TO SHARE KIND OF
YOU KNOW BRIEFLY AS A MEMBER OF
THE GEOCHEMISTRY- WHEN I FIRST
GOT THERE AND READING THROUGH
THEN ALICE'S- MAYBE THE SECOND
OR THIRD WEEK I'M REALIZING
THERE'S ACTUALLY SOME. PRETTY
INTERESTING COMMENTS COMMENTARY
AND THESE ANALYSIS AND WHAT I'M
JUST CRACKED ME UP AND I START
LAUGHING- WHO IS WRITING THIS
STUFF. AND THEN OF COURSE MY
STAFF- MISSION RICHARD PAUL AND
SHORTLY AFTER THAT I GOT AN-
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET HIM. AND- A.
AND BUILD A RELATIONSHIP WITH
THEM AS A MEMBER OF THAT
COMMITTEE IN HIS ANALYSIS OR YOU
ARE ALWAYS SPOT ON. INFORMATIVE
FUNNY. OFTEN SATIRICAL AND MOST
OF ALL THOUGHT PROVOKING.
RICHARD ALWAYS HIT THE NAIL ON
THE HEAD WHEN A BILL PROPOSED
CREATING A NEW STATE AGENCY
DEPARTMENT OR BUREAU. AS HE
OFTEN ASKED POINTED QUESTIONS
SUCH AS IT IS THERE NO OTHER
EXISTING GOVERNMENT ENTITY THAT
CAN BE UTILIZED INSTEAD OF
REINVENTING THE WHEEL. AGAIN
HERE'S A FAVORITE PASSAGE THAT
RICHARD OFTEN PINNED TO QUOTE.
WHY DO WE NEED A SEPARATE AND
DISTINCT COMMISSION TO STUDY.
THIS ISSUE YET AGAIN WHY
ESTABLISHED YET ANOTHER
COMMISSION IN THE STATE
GOVERNMENT WHEN THE GOVERNOR HAS
ALREADY ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER CREATING ESSENTIALLY THE
SAME THING. AND I WELL MAYBE A
QUESTION TO ALEX AZAR WOULD BE
IS HOW MANY TIMES DID THAT SHOW
UP IN IN A IN AN ANALYSIS. ONE
OF RICHARD'S FAVORITE TARGETS
WAS THE LITANY OF EXEMPTIONS.
AND CARVE OUTS OF THE
LEGISLATURE MAKES EVERY YEAR TO
THE TIED HOUSE LAW. WITH RICHARD
OFTEN RAISING THE QUESTION OF
HOW ABOUT LETTING THE MODERN.
MARKET PLACE DEAL WITH THIS
RATHER THAN PROPPING UP THIS R.
K. GOVERNMENT SYSTEM OF CONTROL.
RICHARD STAYED. TRUE TO THE FREE
MARKET PRINCIPLES AND WROTE. THE
ABC ACTORS PUNCHED FULL OF HOLES
ALREADY. WHY NOT JUST FIX THIS
SECTION OF LAW SO THAT EVERY NEW
DEVELOPMENT STADIUM ARENA
THEATRE ETCETERA. DOES NOT NEED
TO COME CRAWLING TO THE
LEGISLATURE SEEKING LEGAL
EXEMPTIONS SO THAT THEY MAY
CONDUCT WHAT IN ANY OTHER
INDUSTRY WOULD BE CONSIDERED
COMMON BUSINESS PRACTICES.
SOMETIMES THOSE ANALYSIS ARE
HARD TO READ FOR SOME OF THE
FOLKS THAT WE WORK WITH HERE IN
THE CAPITAL. BUT I THINK THE
MEMBERS OF OUR CAUCUS AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE ENTIRELY.
ARE GONNA MISS. SEEING RICHARD
AROUND EVERYDAY WITH HIS- HAPPY
COMMITTED DEMEANOR TO THE
SERVICE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN HIS RETIREMENT.
WE'RE GONNA MISS IS THAT HIS
TOUGH BUT ENTERTAINING ANALYSIS
TO REALIGN AS WE SCRUTINIZE THE
ALL TOO MANY PROPOSALS TO
INCREASE THE SIZE OF GOVERNMENT
. RICHARD THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE TO ALL OF US WE WISH YOU
WELL IN RETIREMENT AND FOR A
LONG AND MANY HEALTHY YEARS TO
BE ABLE TO ENJOY IT. THANK YOU.
SENATOR GROWTH WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CONCLUDE. THANK YOU MADAM FOR A
PRESIDENT I'D LIKE TO THINK OF
THE SENATORS WHO SPOKE ON BEHALF
OF RICHARD TODAY- WE PREVIOUSLY
PRESENTED THIS FRAMED A
RESOLUTION TO RICHARD. AND TO
FOR ALL OF HIS ACCOMPLICES
WORKING IN THE LEGISLATURE FOR
MORE THAN THREE DECADES RICHARD
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR OVER THREE
DEDICATED DECADES AND YOUR
DEDICATION AND UNWAVERING
SERVICE TO THE PEOPLE. I ALSO
WANT TO SAY ONE MORE TIME. R.
ROGERS AND GREG I KNOW THAT YOU
ARE- NOT FAMILY BUT BIOLOGICAL
FAMILY TO RICHARD. AND THAT BRAD
IS HIS DEVOTED BROTHER. BUT IF I
COULD- BESTOW ANY- TITLE ON BOTH
OF YOU GREG AND ROGER I WOULD
LIKE TO SAY YOU HAVE BEEN THE
GREATEST ON BIOLOGICAL BROTHERS
OR FAMILY. THAT RICHARD COULD
EVER POSSIBLY HAVE SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE TO THIS
EXTRAORDINARY MAN. AND HIS
DEDICATION TO OUR STATE AND
MEMBERS WOULD YOU PLEASE JOIN ME
IN A ROUND OF APPLAUSE TO HONOR
RICHARD PAUL FOR HIS DEDICATED
SERVICE. I THANK YOU NUMBER TEN
OR NUMBER. A BIG THANK YOU TO
RICHARD PAUL AND CONGRATULATIONS
ON HIS RETIREMENT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO MESSAGES MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED RED AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. INTRODUCTION
AND FIRST READING OF BILLS.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILLS. EIGHT TWENTY NINE
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT THIRTY ONE
AND SENATE CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT SIX. MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. THERE
ARE FOUR AMENDMENT AT THE DESK
AND THEY WILL BE DEEMED ADOPTED
. THIS IS THE TIME TO REMOVE
BELTS FROM THE INACTIVE FILE.
SENATOR DODD. MADAM PRESIDENT-
PLEASE REMOVE THE FOLLOWING
ITEMS FROM THE INACTIVE FILE
PLACE AMONG SENATE THIRD READING
S. B. THREE SEVENTY THAT'S FILE
OUGHT NOT FILE ITEM A. ELEVEN S.
B. TWO SIXTEEN FILE ITEM EIGHT
TWELVE SP SEVEN SEVENTEEN FILE
ITEM E. THIRTEEN AT S. B. TWENTY
FILE ITEM A SIXTEEN THANK YOU.
SO ORDERED CENTER WINNER. OF AN
UNPRECEDENTED- PLEASE REMOVE
FROM INACTIVE FILE- SP ONE OF
SEVEN WHICH IS FILE NUMBER EIGHT
TWENTY FIVE AN SP TWO THREE FOUR
WHICH HAS FILE NOT NUMBER.
EIGHTY FORTY THREE THANK YOU. SO
ORDERED SIX SENATOR NELSON.
MADAM PRESIDENT I DID NOT GET MY
MICROPHONE UP QUICK ENOUGH E
JUST ADOPTED SOME AMENDMENTS CAN
SOMEONE INFORMED THE BODY OF
THOSE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS OR
SUBSTANTIVE AMENDMENTS. WE'LL
GET TO THAT INFORMATION WE JUST
NEED A COUPLE OF MINUTES IF WE
COULD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR NELSON. CENTER THERE
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT-
PLEASE REMOVE FROM THE INACTIVE
FILE FINAL ITEM EIGHTY SIX SP
SIX OH TWO AND FINALLY TO A
SEVEN SP FIVE EIGHTEEN. SO
ORDERED. SENATOR PARDON TINA.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT TO
PLEASE REMOVE. ITEM EIGHT TEN SP
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT FROM THE
INACTIVE FILE. THE ORDER SENATOR
ALAN YES I'D LIKE TO REMOVE FROM
THE ACTIVE FILE SP FIFTY FOUR
THIS IS ITEM EIGHTY TWO SP FIVE
OH TWO FILE IN A MAY THIRTY AN
S. C. EIGHT TWO FIVE SIXTY ONE.
VETERAN PRESIDENT SO ORDERED.
ANYONE ELSE. SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU- MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS BY RICE TO MAKE A MOTION
TO REMOVE MY BILL SB SEVEN FOUR
SIX FILE NUMBER EIGHT TWENTY SIX
FROM THE INACTIVE FILE THANK YOU
. SO ORDERED. OKAY. OKAY MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR SENATOR BATES. IN MY HONOR. I AM. THANK YOUR
MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF JENNIFER PERRY AND DR BLOSSOM
VIA LOBOS FOR REAPPOINTMENT TO
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BOARD OF GOVERNORS MISS
PERRY IS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CHILDREN'S ACTION
NETWORK. AND DOCTOR VIA LOBOS IS
THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR
THE MILITARY SERVICES DIVISION
THAT CENTER STONE THEY WERE
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON SEPTEMBER SEVENTH ON A
UNANIMOUS FIVE ZERO VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
I ARCHULETA I. ATKINS BEFORE I
FACE I BACKER HI PORGES HI
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM I
PROTESTING FIVE DALLY. I DON. I
THEY'RE AWESOME HI A COMMON HI
LASER I CONSOLIDATE HIGH GROWTH
I HEARD SPURRED BY WESTERN. HI
HER TADO JONES I CAN ORDER
LAYERED I LIVE ON. THE MOON HI
WIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A TRAIL OF BOTH I PAM
I PERSON TINA. I BROUGHT HI
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN I AM
BERG I LIKE HOW SKI. HI WINNER I
WILL. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. HER TADO. CAN LONGER
MELINDA'S I WELL. FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE APARTMENT IS
CONFIRMED.
MEMBERS MOVING BACK
TO SENATOR NELSON'S- QUESTION
THE ANSWER IS THAT THE
AMENDMENTS ARE SEPT SOME ARE
SUBSTANTIVE AND SOME ARE
TECHNICAL IN NATURE AND- THERE
IS STUFF IN THE BACK THAT CAN-
DISCUSS THAT FURTHER. SENATOR
NELSON AT THE ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION IS- WITH WHETHER THE
AMENDMENTS WERE TECHNICAL OR
SUBSTANTIVE THERE ARE SOME THAT
ARE SUBSTANTIVE SOME THAT ARE
TECHNICAL AND STAFF HAS A LIST
OF THOSE IN THE BACK SHOULD YOU
WISH TO REVIEW THEM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT QUESTION IF
THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
MEMBERS. SENATOR ATKINS THE DESK
IS CLEAR. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
AGAIN OUR FIRST DAY BACK I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF EXCITEMENT AND
A LOT TO DO- SO I WISH YOU A
GOOD AFTERNOON AND GOING INTO
THIS WEEK THE NEXT FLOOR SESSION
IS SCHEDULED FOR THIS THURSDAY
JANUARY SIXTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
AT NINE AM SEE YOU THEN CALLING
. THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME
THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE. WE WILL RECONVENE ON
THURSDAY AT NINE AM.